[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend zusammen
Champions League Dienstag heute ein
Thema später bei dir im Sport ist heute
dran guten Abend und wir blicken jetzt
auf unsere Themen
der doppelwumms und der Streit ums Geld
beim Spitzentreffen mit dem Kanzler
verlangen die Länder der Bund muss sich
stärker an den Kosten des
entlastungspakets beteiligen
braunkohledeal gegen Energie Notlage rWE
will jetzt mehr Kohle fördern dafür aber
früher aussteigen
und Pakistan nach der Flut viele
Menschen haben alles verloren und wissen
nicht wie sie über den Winter kommen
sollen
[Musik]
Deutschland stemmt sich mit kaum
vorstellbaren Summen den Krisen unserer
Zeit entgegen zur Stunde beraten Bund
und Länder über das schon beschlossene
dritte Entlastungspaket und die
Finanzierung des sogenannten
abwehrschirms in Höhe von 200 Milliarden
Euro strittig vor allem wer zahlt wie
viel beispielsweise beim Wohngeld das
deutlich ausgeweitet werden soll dann
geht es um einen Nachfolger für das 9
euro-ticket und auch beim Thema
Flüchtlinge gibt es Streit über die
Finanzen Bernd Benthin berichtet
bevor es ins Kanzleramt geht legen die
16 länderchefinnen und Chefs ihre Linie
fest heißt konkret bei den Finanzen der
Bund fordere zu viel die Länder hätten
schon genug zu tragen dass wir bei der
Finanzierung faire Lastenverteilung
brauchen ist glaube ich völlig klar es
ist deshalb vor allen Dingen auch so
weil wir in eigener Verantwortung sowohl
Länder als auch Kommunen auch Lasten zu
tragen haben in ihrem Beschlussvorschlag
fordern die Länder der Bund solle die
Kosten für das Wohngeld in Zukunft
vollständig übernehmen für das geplante
69 euro-ticket soll er die zusätzlichen
Beträge beisteuern bei der Aufnahme von
geflüchteten soll er sich weiter zur
finanziellen Mitverantwortung bekennen
der Finanzminister bremst es kann auch
nicht sein dass wenn ich das in aller
Höflichkeit zu sagen darf Länder einfach
Haushaltsüberschüsse erzielen und der
Bund ist in den tiefen roten Zahlen und
muss Krisenmanagement machen die
dringendste Forderung der Länder an den
Bund die versprochenen
milliardenschweren energiepreisdeckel
müssten jetzt sehr so schnell kommen und
substanzielle Entlastungen bringen
das geht darum dass zuallererst die
Energiepreise runter müssen der
Strompreis muss runter der Gaspreis muss
runter ist davor seinem Bums kein
wümchen werden sondern es muss jetzt
endlich gehandelt werden und es ist die
Aufgabe der Regierung wie genau eine
gaspreisbremse funktionieren könnte das
soll eine Kommission Erarbeiten der
Wirtschaftsminister erhöht schon mal den
Druck die Empfehlung solle jetzt bald
kommen parallel dazu arbeitet die
gaskommission die wir gebeten haben die
Arbeit vorzuziehen jedenfalls die
Empfehlung für eine gaspreisbremse
vorzuziehen also nicht Ende Oktober erst
sondern möglichst Anfang Oktober schon
man wolle mehr Klarheit vom Bund was
Energie-
ja die Bund länderrunde in Berlin hat
Theo Koll genau im Blick Theo es geht um
eine Menge Geld und wer ist am Ende
bezahlt was zeichnet sich ab wonach
könnte es aussehen also ehrlich gesagt
es sieht sehr nach einer halbgaren
Veranstaltung aus den und das hat der
niedersächsische Ministerpräsident heute
glasklar vorhergesagt solange nicht
festgelegt sei wie der gaspreisdeckel
aussieht und wie die Entlastungen zu
beziffern sein solange könnte man heute
nicht mehr als einen Zwischenstand
liefern und dieser Deckel bleibt bis auf
weiteres ein unbekanntes Wesen
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck hat es
kommissionsergebnis wir haben es eben
gehört zwar für Anfang Oktober
angekündigt aber wir hören das mit
Anfang Oktober erst kommende Woche
gemeint sei Ministerpräsident wüst
nannte den gaspreisdeckel und den 200
Milliarden Abwehrschirm der Ampel heute
auch gleich in der Wundertüte bei der
noch unklar sei was drin ist über die
sich aber schon mal alle freuen die
Frage wird sein inwieweit heute dennoch
die offenen Finanzierungswünsche der
Länder abgearbeitet werden können und da
liegt man weit auseinander die Länder
informieren dass der Bund Entlastungen
beschließe und ihnen einen Teil der
Rechnung schicke und Finanzminister
Lindner betont den Ländern ging es
finanziell viel besser als dem Bund mein
aktueller Zwischenstand aus dem
Beratungen ist die meisten Beschlüsse
brauchen offensichtlich noch Zeit
möglicherweise bis zur nächsten MPK Ende
Oktober dann danke für die Informationen
könnte also ein langer Abend werden in
Berlin danke Theo Deutschland will also
viel Geld in die Hand nehmen das kommt
nicht in allen EU-Staaten gut an
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner verteidigt
die geplante gaspreisbremse Ziel sei
möglichst wenig der 200 Milliarden Euro
bis 2024 einzusetzen kritik gab es auch
heute im Kreis der europäischen
Wirtschafts- und Finanzminister einige
Länder fürchten eine
Wettbewerbsverzerrung weil sie sich so
teure Programme nicht leisten können und
jetzt wird der Ruf laut nach einem
EU-weiten Hilfspaket das über neue
Kredite finanziert werden soll da wollen
wir nachfragen und zwar bei Florian
neuhahn Luxemburg wo sich die
Wirtschafts- und Finanzminister
getroffen haben Florian wie ist die
Kritik einzuschätzen und wie wird sich
Deutschland verhalten
da die heftige Kritik hat die
Bundesregierung hier offenbar auf dem
falschen Fuß erwischt da wird
Solidarität gefordert da wird vor allem
Subventionswettlauf gewarnt und der
ungarische Ministerpräsident Viktor
Orban der ja gern mal kräftiger austeilt
der warnte Deutschland Zitat gar vor dem
Beginn des Kannibalismus in der EU wenn
man mal die Polemik abzieht dann hat man
muss man folgendes sagen die Kritik
zeigt vor allem wie viele Regierungen in
dieser Krise mit dem Rücken zur Wand
stehen und wie groß die Sorge ist vieler
davor dass Deutschland sich hier in
dieser schwierigen Lage einen
Wettbewerbsvorteil verschafft und da
kommt dieser Vorschlag aus den Reihen
der EU-Kommission vielen gerade ganz
recht nämlich die Idee eines neuen aus
gemeinsamen europäischen Schulden
finanzierten Fonds wie schon zu Zeiten
der corona-pandemie der Finanzminister
Lindner hat diesem Vorschlag hier Post
wendend eine Absage erteilt später kam
auch eine solche vom deutschen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz aber die
Debatte wird sich nicht mehr austreten
lassen ich gehe davon aus dass die
Bundesregierung hier in den nächsten
Wochen massiv unter Druck wird sich da
doch noch zu bewegen dann vielen Dank
für diesen aktuellen nachrichtenstand
aus Luxemburg war das vorher neu an der
Energiekonzern RWE will den
braunkohleausstieg um 8 Jahre vorziehen
auf 2030 aber zunächst wird der Abbau
ausgeweitet zwei Kraftwerke laufen
länger als ursprünglich geplant darauf
hat sich der Konzern mit dem Bundes und
dem NRW Wirtschaftsministerium geeinigt
einige vom Braunkohleabbau bedrohte
Ortschaften bleiben erhalten die
Siedlung lützerath im Rheinischen Revier
ein Symbol des Widerstands wird
allerdings abgebaggert dort gefärber
dazu
lützerath bleibt steht an den Häusern im
rheinischen braunkohle-revier an den Ort
haben sich die riesenbagger immer weiter
herangefressen nun soll lützerath
weichen wegen des ukraine-kriegs werde
die Kohle unterm Dorf gebraucht
das bedeutet lützerath muss bergbaulich
in Anspruch genommen werden also
abgebaggert werden wir erhalten dafür
eine politische Verständigung acht Jahre
früher aus der Kohle auszusteigen
Kohleausstieg 2030 vereinbart mit RWE
die Grünen Spitze müht sich diese
Botschaft zu betonen denn es sind eben
auch grüne die gerade das Aus für
lützerath beschlossen haben die
Mengen an CO2 Emissionen die jetzt im
Boden gebunden bleiben sind doch
erheblich es ist ein guter Tag für den
Klimaschutz ich hoffe dass das auch von
der Klima und Umweltbewegung so gesehen
und am Ende jedenfalls weitgehend
akzeptiert wird
die Aktivisten vor Ort sehen keinen
guten Tag sie sind enttäuscht und sie
kündigen Widerstand an wir sind wütend
über dieses Ergebnis weil der
Kohleausstieg 2030 viel zu spät ist
natürlich ist klar dass die Grünen hier
nicht das gehalten haben was sie
versprochen haben was uns jetzt noch
bleibt ist einfach hier zu sein und
damit dass wir hier sind uns dem
entgegenzustellen der Ort lützerath ist
ein Symbol für die Klimabewegung
geworden und die ruft nun zu weiteren
Protesten auf
jetzt zum Ukraine Krieg Präsident
selensky hat Gespräche mit Putins
Russland per Dekret ausgeschlossen nach
der Annexion vier ukrainischer Regionen
seien Verhandlung mit dem russischen
Präsidenten unmöglich und militärisch
meldet die ukrainische Armee Erfolge im
Süden und auch im Osten des Landes
Tobias Häfner berichtet
Männer die Russland an die Front
geschickt hat liegen Tod auf einer
Straße in Liman in der Ostukraine nicht
weit entfernt Bergen ukrainische
Soldaten einen gefallenen Kameraden
die Stadt ist zurückerobert aber
normales Leben bleibt unmöglich kein
Strom kein Gas kaum Wasser Menschen wie
die 85-Jährige Valentina müssen für jede
mal Zeit improvisieren viele in
Uniformen sind froh und unglücklich
zugleich
besonders wir kämpfen für unser Land für
die Kinder aber das alles hat einen sehr
sehr hohen Preis
auch weiter im Süden Gelingen der
Ukraine offenbar Geländegewinne auf die
Russisch kontrollierte Region herson
rückt die Armee von mehreren Seiten vor
kontrolliert inzwischen die hier
hellgelb markierten Gebiete orange ist
in Hand der Russen der Präsident in Kiew
erklärt die Erfolge so
die Besatzer schicken viele Männer in
den Kampf ohne Training ohne Erfahrung
die russischen Kommandeure brauchen
einfach irgendwen um in die Fußstapfen
der Toten zu treten das wiederholt sich
so kämpft Russland aber so wird es auch
verlieren
Moskau versucht die angeblich gute Moral
seiner Truppen mit diesen Bildern des
Verteidigungsministeriums zu untermauern
Reservisten in Ausbildung wo genau ist
unklar
das Ergebnis der scheinreferenten in der
Ostukraine hat nun auch das russische
Oberhaus gebilligt Putins Unterschrift
fehlt noch dann existiert nach Moskauer
Lesart neues Staatsgebiet der gewünschte
Grenzverlauf aber bleibt offen in einer
Region in der jeder Meter Land umkämpft
bleibt
bei ihrem Besuch in Polen hat
Außenministerin baerbock
Reparationsforderungen erneut
zurückgewiesen aus Sicht der
Bundesregierung sei die Frage
abgeschlossen das sagte bärbock bei
einem Besuch bei ihrem polnischen
Amtskollegen rau zugleich betonte sie
deutschland stehe ohne wenn und aber zu
seiner historischen Verantwortung die
Regierung in Warschau beziffert die
durch den Zweiten Weltkrieg entstandenen
Schäden auf mehr als 1,3 Billionen Euro
neue Provokation aus Nordkorea zum
ersten Mal seit fünf Jahren hat das Land
eine Rakete in den japanischen Luftraum
geschossen die Mittelstreckenrakete flog
insgesamt
4.500 Kilometer über die japanischen
Inseln hinweg bevor sie dann im Pazifik
abstürzte japans Regierung rief die
Menschen in den nördlichen Provinzen auf
in Kellern Schutz zu suchen und
verurteilte den Raketentest als
Gewaltakt
in Iran explodiert die Wut seit dem Tod
der 22-jährigen Martha Amini die in
Polizeihaft verstarb nachdem sie ihr
Kopftuch nicht richtig getragen haben
soll gingen mutige Frauen trotz brutaler
Repressionen auf die Straße auch wenn
das mulla-regime das Internet lahm legt
und es nur wenige Bilder gibt die
Proteste dehnen sich aus und stellen
längst nicht mehr nur das Kopftuch in
Frage Lück wahlport
unterrichtsboykott der Studentinnen und
Studenten heute an der Technischen
Universität Tehran draußen vor dem
Eingang bezieht bewaffnete
bereitschaftspolizeistellung ihr seid
eine Schande für das Land rufen die
Studierenden ihnen entgegen in sakface
der Heimatstadt von Marsa almine im
kurdischen Westen gehen SchülerInnen auf
die Straße tot dem Diktator fordern sie
Frauen Leben Freiheit diese
protestparole lassen die Behörden
eiligste über tünnchen ausgerechnet an
der Fassade einer Eliteschule des
Regimes intera der Präsident bekräftigte
heute im Parlament noch einmal dass die
Proteste von Amerika und Israel
gesteuert würden um Irans Fortschritte
zunichte zu machen
der Feind will dass unsere Bürger die
Hoffnung verlieren deshalb stellen Sie
unsere Probleme und Schwächen völlig
übertrieben da
das Staatsfernsehen berichtet über neue
Sanktionen von US-Präsident beiden gegen
Iran dass beiden damit den Mut der
Iranerinnen unterstützen und Gewalttäter
gegen friedliche Demonstranten im
bestrafen möchte wird nicht erwähnt
es ist schrecklich traurig es ist
grausam die jungen Leute wollen endlich
Gerechtigkeit sie wollen Freiheit und
dieses System quält uns seit 40 Jahren
nach Angaben von Menschenrechtsgruppen
wurden bei den Protesten bislang 92
Menschen getötet und mehr als tausend
festgenommen
den Nobelpreis für Physik teilen sich in
diesem Jahr drei quantenforscher der
Österreicher anton Zeilinger der
Franzose alla Aspe und der US-Amerikaner
John F closer gemeinsam erkunden Sie
etwas was kleiner ist als Atome nämlich
Elementarteilchen die können auch über
riesige Entfernungen hinweg Partner
haben ändert man den Zustand eines
Teilchens ändert sich gleichzeitig auch
der Zustand des anderen diese
Erkenntnisse sollen bald etwa
superschnelle Computer ermöglichen
nach Pakistan und zu den schweren
Überschwemmungen die das Landheim
suchten vor dreieinhalb Monaten begannen
die immensen Regenfälle inzwischen haben
sie nachgelassen aber not- und Leid
bleiben etwa 1700 Menschen rissen die
Fluten in den Tod wer überlebte der
verlor meist sein zu Hause zur
Obdachlosigkeit kommen Krankheiten wie
Malaria und Hunger gibt es auch 5,8
Millionen Menschen sind wegen zu knapper
Nahrung in Gefahr Nomen Odenthal
mit seinen Händen und mit letzter Kraft
arbeitet nasirachmatt 12 Stunden am Tag
oft untersängender Sonne baut er Mauern
aus Lehm an der Stelle wo die Familie
seit Jahren wohnte in einem Haus das ist
nicht mehr gibt dass ihnen die Flut
genommen hat
der Winter kommt dann brauchen wir ein
Dach über den Kopf wir versuchen also
unser Haus wieder aufzubauen mit dem was
wir haben aber uns fehlt das Geld um
Steine oder anderes Material zu kaufen
es ist schwierig
Millionen in Pakistan stehen vor dem
Nichts und vor enormen Problemen kaum
sauberes wasserkrankheiten breiten sich
aus es fehlt an Nahrung Medikamenten an
allem viele sind traumatisiert haben
Angehörige verloren ihrer Existenz
verzweiflung macht sich breit
uns geht es allen gleich alle unserer
Häuser hat die Flut genommen aber ich
habe ihnen gesagt sitzt nicht da und
wartet auf Hilfe macht Lehm sucht Steine
findet Wellblech für ein Dach lasst uns
tun was wir können dann wird Allah uns
beistehen
nasia und seine Frau haben acht Kinder
als Obstverkäufer konnte er die Familie
so gerade über die Runden bringen aber
Obst gibt es hier nicht mehr wie es
weitergeht weiß nassieren nicht nur dass
es weitergehen muss
einen toten kannst du nicht mehr töten
mein Leben war vorbei an dem Tag als die
Flut kam es geht nur darum unsere Kinder
zu retten sie sind alles was wir haben
wir kämpfen für Sie
jeden Tag jede Stunde jeden Augenblick
ein Kampf das ist Pakistan nach der
großen Flut
und wenn sie den Menschen in Pakistan
helfen wollen können Sie das über das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe tun die
iban.de
65-100
400-600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF
Nothilfe Pakistan und diese Angaben auch
auf spenden.zdf.de und auf der ZDF
Textseite 89.0
nach rund 14 Jahren Bauzeit ist in
Brandenburg Deutschlands größter Lift
eröffnet worden ein gigantisches
Schiffshebewerk mit der Anlage können
auch größere Frachter einen
Höhenunterschied von 36 Metern auf dem
oder Havelkanal überwinden das verkürzt
den Weg für Containerschiffe zwischen
Deutschland und Polen die Baukosten
betrugen 520 Millionen Euro
so und jetzt zur Fußball Champions
League da sind gleich drei deutsche
Vereine dran Christen die Bayern spielen
schon gegen Pilsen und Europa League
Gewinner Eintracht Frankfurt will
nachher auch sein Heimvorteil nutzen
gegen Tottenham Hotspur gestärkt aus dem
Bundesliga-Sieg gegen Tabellenführer
Union Berlin soll der kurzfristige
Ausfall von Mario Götze selbstbewusst
kompensiert werden
Mario Götze kann nicht spielen das
Sprunggelenk beim Torschützen vom
Wochenende ist verletzt aber der
Ligaauftritt insgesamt macht Mut Torwart
Kevin Trapp scheint auf die starke
Tottenham Offensive gut vorbereitet zu
sein zudem hatten die Engländer zuletzt
die erste Saison Niederlage der Premier
League einzustecken Duell mit hin- und
Rückspiel in einer Woche beide
Mannschaften Punkte gleich in der Gruppe
ausverkauftes Haus also von dem her ist
eigentlich das sind die Voraussetzungen
perfekt und so ein perfekten Abend
wünschen wir uns auch das ausverkaufte
Haus ist auch der UEFA zu verdanken die
den Verein nach den Ausschreitungen
Mitte September in Marseille nur mit
einer Geldstrafe belegte die Zuschauer
aber weiter im Blick hat bei erneutem
Fehlverhalten drohen weitere Strafen
sportlich unter Erfolgsdruck Bayer
Leverkusen der Liga vorletzte sollte in
Portugal beim Gruppen letzten FC Porto
gewinnen um auf Kursrichtung
Achtelfinale in der Königsklasse zu
bleiben und um auch die eigene
Trainerdiskussion einzudämmen
die trainerbegrüßung mit Julian
nagelsmann vor dem Match am vergangenen
Freitag könnte für Gerardo silvane die
vorletzte in der Bundesliga gewesen sein
sollte sein Team auch in dieser Woche
heute gegen Porto und am Samstag gegen
Schalke erneut enttäuschen dürfte sein
Vertrag mit Leverkusen aufgelöst werden
die Resultate seit Saisonbeginn sind
nicht zufriedenstellend und das macht
etwas mit einem doch was soll ein
Trainer machen wenn selbst sein Torhüter
und Kapitän Lukas Radetzky gegen die
Bayern haltbare Bälle durchlässt
oder völlig unerklärliches lapstick
Nummern darbietet wie schon die
Begrüßung könnte also auch die
Verabschiedung mit nagelsmann für
seehuane eine der letzten in der
Bundesliga gewesen sein
ja und alles zur Champions League morgen
Abend dann hier bei uns 23 Uhr im ZDF
Christian vielen vielen Dank die
europäische Weltraumorganisation die hat
sich was besonders ausgedacht um die
nächste Generation von raumfahrerinnen
zu inspirieren sie hat nämlich Barbie in
den Weltraum geschickt um junge Mädchen
dazu zu bringen selbst an große Sprünge
zu denken die Puppe ist ja Astronautin
Samantha Christopher retti nachempfunden
Europas erster weiblicher Kommandantin
der ISS
so es gibt einen Sommer Nachschlag beim
Wetter morgen kann es bis zu 25 Grad
geben Details hat es den teerli gleich
wir empfehlen Ihnen das heute journal um
21 Uhr mit Marietta Slomka im Namen des
19 Uhr heute Teams sage ich danke fürs
zuschauen schönen Abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter sehr warme Luft
erreicht uns aus dem Südwesten Europas
Spanien Frankreich und bis nach
Deutschland ja da steigen die
Temperaturen vor allem aber im Südwesten
am Oberrhein da werden bis zu 25 Grad
erreicht ja und auch eine Kaltfront
spielt morgen eine Rolle zum späten
Nachmittag und in den Abendstunden
erreicht uns diese Kaltfront dann gibt
es viele Wolken und vor allem an der
Nordsee dann regen schauen wenn die
Nacht im Norden viele Wolken insgesamt
trocken im Süden klar das auf und es
bildet sich Nebel vor allem in
Gewässernähe Temperaturen gehen zurück
auf zwei bis fünf Grad im Südosten hier
am kältesten und am mildesten mit 14
Grad Richtung Nordsee und morgen nach
Auflösung von Nebelfeldern gibt es viel
Sonnenschein Richtung Donau kann das
länger dauern ansonsten aber Wolken
Zunahme im Nordwesten mit der Kaltfront
und vor allem viel Winter an der Nordsee
und in den höheren Lagen teils stürmisch
Temperaturen liegen bei 25 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands und 18 Grad zum
Beispiel nach Norden und nach Nordosten
hin die kommenden Tage ja es geht
trocken und mit viel Sonnenschein weiter
wenn der Nebel sich auflöst Donnerstag
bei 16 bis 22 Grad schönen Abend